Breast is this positive study?
No,
it's maps of meaning positive psych.
It's definitely not that.
Why might you be villainous?
Well,
first of all,
because you can be.
That's a big deal.
You can be.
It's actually an offshoot of empathy.
This is something that took me decades
to figure out.
I figured it out when I was studying the
book of Genesis because in the book of
Genesis,
people become self conscious and they
immediately have the knowledge of good
and evil.
I just couldn't figure it out.
It's like,
what?
What the hell is the relationship
between that?
And then really I tell you,
I thought about that like for 30 years
trying to puzzle that out and then I
realized what it was.
If you're self conscious,
you can,
you can conceptualize yourself as being
you know that you are and you know what
you're like and you know what hurts you
and what doesn't,
and as soon as you know what hurts you,
you know what hurts her,
and so that's the knowledge of good and
evil that comes along with being self
conscious as this is something that
distinguishes human beings from every
other animal.
You know a lion will eat you,
but it doesn't really want to tear you
apart slowly,
just for the fun of it.
Well,
it eats you.
It just wants to eat you and you,
you know,
you could call that evil it socks,
that's for sure,
but animals are beyond good and evil in
that sense,
but human beings,
man,
we can aim our malevolence and we're
really good at it because we can imagine
God,
this would hurt and if it hurts me,
man,
it's really going to hurt you.
So.
And you need to know that you're like
that because you are like that.
And if you don't know you're like that,
or if you don't think you're like that,
you're even more like that than you
think because the people who are most
like that or people who don't think
they're like that at all and you have to
contend with that and that's why in many
systems of thinking the world is
conceptualized as a battle between good
and evil and it's inappropriate
conceptualization.
It's a medic conceptualization and
the culture is the wise king in the
tyrant and that's always the case and
you're always stuck with that because as
an individual with your negative side
and your positive side year,
negative side is the resentful side that
is irritated that the limited conditions
of being and the suffering that entails
and it's arbitrary and unfair nature and
no wonder you got that side has a case
to make.
It's not trivial in in the brothers
Karamazov,
that argument is laid out beautifully.
There's a character Alioscha who's a
monk,
monastery novitiate,
and not really a sparkling intellect,
but a very good person and he has a
brother Ivan and Ivan's a vicious genius
and Ivan just take silly Osha apart and
partly he does that by telling a story
about that.
Dostoevsky took this from a news story.
The news story was that this mother and
father had taken their young daughter
and locked her in the outhouse overnight
when it was like 30 below and you know,
she stayed out there crying and
screaming and froze to death and I even
basically said to Lee Osha,
you know,
a world in which that could happen
should not be.
That's good argument.
You know when you can multiply that by
millions of examples.
So the part of us that is opposed to
being and resentful,
it's got a point,
man.
The problem as far as I can tell is that
if you act that out,
then it makes what you're objecting to
worse.
Now you might be happy about that and
you might think,
well,
people couldn't be consciously pursuing
that,
but yes they can.
I would recommend a book called Pans,
Ram if you're interested in that sort of
thing.
It's a book written by a man who raped
1200 men and killed dozens and burn
things down to the ground every chance
he got and tried to start a war between
England and the US and who is aimed at
nothing but mayhem and he wrote an
autobiography at the request of a doctor
who had befriended him and he tells you
exactly what he did and why the story,
heroin adversary,
adversary order and tyranny,
destruction and creation.
That's the basic landscape and outside
of that chaos.
And so let's take a break.
Here's another way of looking at this
idea.
The individual is the person who pays
attention and explores and masters or
who looks away
and the
the person is still inhabits unexplored
territory and this is unexplored
territory,
and so wherever you go,
there's you have two halves of you
that you have to contend with and
wherever you are with people,
there's the society with its tyrannical
and beneficial nature and this society
in some sense is that match between what
you're doing and what's happening.
It's really important to get that right
and then unexplored territory that's
wherever and whenever.
What you're doing stops working and so
it's not exactly a geographical idea,
you know,
because when you think of explored
territory,
you think of geographic landscape like
that,
like the domain of an animal,
you know,
or like your house and you know that's,
that's definitely an element of it,
but you know,
if you're in your house and a snake
comes into your living room and you're
in there,
it's like,
well that's an important difference
between your house.
One second to go in your house now and
so your house can turn into unexplored,
unexplored territory at the drop of a
hat.
And that's because we live in space and
time and so the unexplored territory is
conceptual.
It's a conceptual territory and it's
just wherever you are,
when things aren't working for you the
way they're supposed to be.
And so,
and these are permanent parts of the
human experience,
which is why I think they are
fundamental characters in our
narratives.
There's always you.
There's some subject of the story and
that subject is an ambivalent person
with many different potentials and
you're always somewhere and with other
people because that's our territory,
right?
I mean we're social beyond comprehension
and you know,
even our primate ancestors,
most of their territory was other
primates and their brains and our brains
are specialized to view the world as an
aggregation of personalities.
It's really important to us and so we
tend to view the whole world that way.
And then unexplored territory.
Well,
that's where you don't know what to do
and but you know,
you do know what to do when you don't
know what to do peculiarly enough.
It's rather nonspecific.
It's this generalized stress response
and so what happens is you freeze,
roughly speaking,
if the threat is enough,
then you produce a lot of cortisol and a
lot of adrenaline so that you're bloody
well ready to move quick and whatever
direction you have to,
and then maybe you pay more attention
and that's what you do when you don't
know what to do.
And the problem with that is as you can
stay in that state forever,
man,
that's kind of what posttraumatic stress
disorder is.
It's like you're just like that all the
time.
And the problem with that is it's a very
uncomfortable.
I mean,
you stay like that for any length of
time.
You're going to get depressed,
you're going to develop an anxiety
disorder,
you're going to get old because you're
burning up resources like mad.
You know,
your system is shunting everything to
maintain that state of emergency
preparation.
And it's exhausting.
It's not where you want to be.
So that's partly why people are so prone
to defend their territories.
They're familiar territory because if
they're familiar territory is invaded or
disrupted,
then they default back to the state of
emergency preparation.
And that's like,
that can unglue you if it's.
If it's profound enough.
You know,
and you guys know this already.
I mean,
I think people experience this most,
particularly when they're betrayed by
someone they have an intimate
relationship with.
You know,
when they're lied to.
There's other ways.
The collapse of a dream or a vision that
you've been pursuing or an illness or
the death in the family.
There's lots of other ways but be is a
really good one because if you're with
someone for a long time,
you trust them.
You have a representation of your past,
you have a representation of you in the
relationship,
you have a representation of them.
You have a representation of of
relationships.
You have a representation of the future.
You get betrayed.
It's like poof.
Even the past isn't what you thought it
was.
You know,
and what about you?
how clueless are you and maybe not at
all or maybe ultimately gullible.
You don't know.
Is it your fault or you know,
or you so clueless that you just can't
protect yourself or was the person
malevolent in some subtle way that you
failed to detect everything's up in the
air,
not good and this idea that human beings
traveled to the underworld and come
back.
It's like it's a really useful thing to
understand because we do that all the
time.
Whenever we fail,
it's like whip down into the underworld
for awhile where everything's in chaos
and then maybe we sort ourselves out.
Bang,
we're back up and so one way of
conceptualizing yourself is not as order
and as not as chaos,
but as the thing that traverses between
the two domains and that I would say is
the mythological hero.